bacteria are tiny one-celled organisms
with their own DNA they have the ability
to divide grow and as is beautifully and
terrifyingly shown here evolve because
what you can't see is how the petri dish
is divided into zones folding increasing
strengths of antibiotics that still
can't stop the bacteria
do not mess with single-celled organisms
this is the work of harvard med
researchers Michael Bain
Tammy Lieberman and Roy Kashani but how
are their bacteria beating the
antibiotic in this experiment regular
ecoli bacteria are placed at the very
ends of a giant petri dish now there's
no antibiotics there but every few
inches increasing concentrations of
antibiotics are added so that right in
the middle there is 1,000 times the
amount of antibiotics required to kill
the e.coli the bacteria which appear
white grow until they encounter a zone
of antibiotics that stops them but then
you see one of the colonies of bacteria
will start growing into that zone
because it has evolved resistance to
that antibiotic
how do bacteria evolve they reproduce by
getting big enough to make a copy of
themselves the idea is that new copy is
exactly the same as the first one but it
doesn't always work like that there's
always a chance that you'll have some
kind of genetic mutation that makes you
a little bit different to the first
bacterial cell this ability to multiply
quickly during which their offspring are
essentially trying out the success or
failure of different random mutations
allows the bacteria to evolve very fast
this is evolution in action we see this
over and over as the bacteria grow
towards the center of the plate this is
a fantastic illustration of why we
shouldn't overuse antibiotics every time
we take antibiotics were exposing
bacteria to them and every time we do
that they're evolving to deal with it